we were wondering if there was
somebody's job this is their full-time
job is to report on sports betting and
Paulie goes yes I know a guy Todd Dewey
he works for the Las Vegas
review-journal
because I'm curious what this means all
this gambling that's gonna happen sports
gambling that's going to happen but Todd
just covers sports betting for the Las
Vegas review-journal
and Todd joins us now Todd how did you
get that John Mead an 510 a hard 235
[Music]
well I've been with the review journal
for a while now and I covered a bunch of
different sports and when mad humans are
former sports betting writer joins Uncle
Brent over at Beeson he asked me to take
over the sports betting bead and I used
to backup him a little covering sports
betting and I'm a sports bettor from a
long time ago and yeah it's kind of a
dream job out to cover sports betting I
wish it gave me a few more winners but
we're working on that okay but what do
you cover in the world of sports betting
well we cover the industry itself and as
far as all the action in Vegas where the
money's going line moves who the sharp
betters are on and the betting public is
on and then we also run contests with
picks with local handicappers and media
members and you know I have some
handicappers making their picks as well
so just the full range from how the
books do to how the players do and try
to make some picks along the way as well
what's the worst bad beat you ever heard
of the worse bad beat everywhere I know
myself was the Yukon Duke game back in
the final four when you come was losing
the whole game of the mecca okafor and
they they cover the spread right at the
end and Chris Duhon raised up court to
hit the half-court three-pointer to burn
the spread we had nothing to do with the
results of the game but you know every
week and that's III remember the bad
beats then then the great wins but I
always tell guys if somebody there's a
bad beat for somebody there's an
unbelievable win for somebody else so it
you you hope it evens out but man those
bad beats they stay with you for a long
time your reaction your your reaction to
what happened with Congress with the
Supreme Court with now legalized
gambling sports gambling what's that
mean what's that mean for Vegas first of
all you know going back to Atlantic City
when when they open people are saying
Vegas that will hurt
and same thing when the proliferation of
casinos across the country they thought
that would hurt the business in Las
Vegas but but it's only increased the
business in Vegas and the same thing
with sports betting a lot of the
oddsmakers
I've talked with out here about it just
think it will grow the market and
introduce a whole new segment of the
population of sports betting in Vegas
will always be the mecca you know making
a pilgrimage to Fenway or Wrigley Field
for baseball people always want to come
to Vegas where all the casinos are all
packed in on the strip and it will
always be the big destination
I can't imagine people you know having a
big guys trip to some other parts of the
country this won't be the same as coming
to Vegas to watch the NC double-a
tournament it will always be kind of a
sports bucket list thing to watch the
tournament at a casino sports book in
Vegas are you allowed to bet on the
Vegas Golden Knights during the season
yes you can NHL oh and with the Raiders
coming here as well neither league has
requested they could have requested a
ban on betting with this you know being
regulated out here at the state's Gaming
Control Board but it has been betting on
the Golden Knights and there's been a
ton of betting on the Golden Knights and
obviously a lot of betters are cashing
in on them all season and there's tons
of liability and big tickets out there
and them to win the Stanley Cup
what about and the Raiders you're going
to be able to bet on the Raiders in Las
Vegas as far as it is now yes you can
bet on the Raiders you can bet you know
as they have all the phone apps out here
you could be sitting in the stadium or
out if the Golden Knights game and
punching in in-progress bets when you're
sitting there in the stadium you can't
bet on UNLV basketball is that still
true now they listed that ban years ago
to in fact to prove that that there was
no issues with Betty in Vegas and that
you know the casinos and bookmakers out
here belong protected the integrity of
the games that the league's talked about
because if there's a fixed game
the bookies are the ones that get hurt
yeah I'm with the leaks and so they just
wanted to prove they'd never be an issue
and and there hasn't been an issue in
over 20 years since that ban was lifted
you could bet on UNLV and right now todd
dewey's joining us he's a reporter for
the Las Vegas review-journal and his job
is to cover sports betting what's the
last time you got the whiff of maybe a
fixed game unusual line moves it was a
college game this year I said it was a
line move but it was nothing to do with
a fix but when I wrote a story earlier
this year about some of the past fixes
you know going back to 94 when Arizona
stayed had that point champion handle in
basketball and and the bookmakers out
here alerted authorities to that and
going back even further Tulane there
hasn't been that many over the years
uncovered Toledo a few years back when I
had basketball and football
I guess there's tons of tennis matches
that that's the easiest one to fix and
that would be in Europe because they
kind of smash you could just say you're
injured and bow out after a couple of
games where was Vegas on the Boston
College Sports Campbell its candled that
that point-shaving scandal did that you
know hit Vegas yeah Henry Henry Hill
yeah yeah Richard the fixer Perry who
obviously had a big hot tub photo and
you and I kind of took down Park out
here but that was more of an illegal
bookmaker operation so that's one of the
things they talked about that didn't hit
Vegas that was just the underground
bookies in and this was you know illegal
sports bookmakers can always spot those
fixes and alert authorities to him but
you know but in a legal bookie he'd be
the last one to call the police and tell
them about a facially bet on anything
you know how much of a bath does Vegas
take if the Golden Knights win the cup
well from talking about a few different
bookmakers the estimates is in the range
of between five and seven million
dollars on futures take
it's to win the Stanley Cup William Hill
which operates 100 a to the 190 books
out here they were and to lose more than
a million perhaps the two million
stations casinos they ran a promotion
where they give thousands of you free
futures bets on the Knights at four to
one in April to win the Stanley Cup
they're going to lose more than a
million you have MGM South Pointe high
six figures and there's four or five
other places with six figures so right
now it's looking about five to seven
million dollars oh that's not bad
I mean what's what's a bad Sunday in
Vegas during the NFL no exactly that's
what a speaker at Jay Kornegay over at
the Westgate sports but yesterday he was
saying you know that loss is comparable
to one of their worse
college football Saturdays or NFL
Sundays where all the favorites and the
overs are coming in
yeah that's but in terms of I'm just
gonna say in terms of this is it's
looking to be the biggest futures loss
ever for this city where you bet on the
teams to win the title before the season
it's not good to catch up with you
hopefully we'll cross pass thanks for
joining us Thank You Bev me Dan back row
that's Todd Dewey Wow sports betting
reporter for the Las Vegas
review-journal
I'm gonna guess he was familiar with the
show a little bit there for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on Direct TV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]